teachers union leader calls for fully
reopening schools this fall this is a
political
story af aft president randy
weingarten called for schools to reopen
full-time in person
this fall and set out multi-million
dollar outreach campaign to coax uh
co-ops uh pronounce that word for me
families back to campuses as president
joe biden administration passes for
quick
resumption of uh regular classes the
chief of the 1.7 million member
labor group said political pressure from
republican lawmakers didn't factor into
her school
reopening call to the aft on thursday
really let me read that one more time
the chief of the 1.7 million member
labor groups said political pressure
from republican lawmakers didn't factor
into her school
reopening call to the aft on thursday
nor she said
did any new coronavirus with biden
administration about school reopening
during the cover 19 pandemic she instead
cited expanded
eligibility for coronavirus vaccines her
own business to schools carrying out the
federal
safety guidance for reopening plus
hundreds of billions of dollars in
federal aid now being delivered to k-12
schools anyways we're going to see
what's going to happen the good news is
that there are finally
people from teachers union realizing
keeping kids at home
not only hurts marriages non-stop you're
hurting people to get back to work
because some parents can't afford to
have a
babysitter to be with the kid when
they're going to school there's a lot of
different risks there finally
i talked to a friend of mine yesterday
she called we had a conversation
together
and she lives in la she's got three kids
her and her husband my husband's one of
my
top five best friends i have good guy
you met him before so
we're having a conversation together and
i said she said so how are things as the
kids have been going back to school the
entire time what are you talking about
yeah there was like slight little break
in texas
but they've been going back to school
you're serious yeah i said how are
things over there in california pat you
understand
no one's going to school they're home
period period
like what are you talking about your
kids too it's as if you're living in a
different world they're
finally getting so here's what's
starting to happen with politics
let me tell you what's starting to
happen with politics democrats and
republicans
okay sometimes when you are a registered
democrat you almost feel obligated to
have to support everything
that is on the ballot box of what all
democrats yeah and sometimes when you're
republican you found kind of feel like
obligated to say
okay yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
right i have to agree with everything
yep
i think what is starting to happen is
people are starting to say dude forget
about being a democrat or a republican
this just doesn't make any sense we
gotta open up the schools what the hell
are we doing here
what are we doing here staying loyal to
a political party let's
open the damn schools and it's starting
to happen tomorrow well i i'm very
very emotional and fired up about this
topic because
here's one thing we learned over the
past 14 years is just how powerful
teachers unions are
and it's extremely political and they
held cities hostage and i'm still
very very annoyed at them i don't think
an industry has taken a hit
more than the teachers industry
educators in general
over the past year because here's what
happens because of these greedy
evil union leaders for the teachers
associations
it paints all of them in that same broad
brush i look at teachers completely
different
and i say this with my daughter being a
teacher
she graduated from pepperdine got a job
in a public school
was doing fine i don't want her joining
the la county
unified school district teachers union i
don't want her to do it and thank god
she got a great job at cavalry christian
which is one of the top
pub or private schools in all of l.a in
the palisades awesome
i know it's a group this is one this is
recent yes phenomenal that's great
it's huge good i know we had a huge
celebration for it was she happy oh my
god she's ecstatic plus she's starting
the soccer program for him too
so i'm she's still doing the diving or
nothing so this is my older daughter oh
pepperdine yeah you got it
okay so i'm just grateful she's not in
the teachers union
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]